I haven't been thrilled with the
different water filter pitchers I've
used recently I always filter my water
and aqua gear recently sent me there
aqua gear filter pitcher which actually
removes more contaminants than a Brita
filter including lead and fluoride and
chromium 6 and heavy metals trace
pharmaceuticals etcetera they've
actually had their filter tested by
independent labs and they publish the
test data on go aqua gear dot com and
i've been using the aqua gear filter
pitcher not only for my drinking water
but also to filter the water for my
espresso machine which some in our
audience are familiar with the filter is
made in the u.s. it's one hundred
percent bpa-free it is one hundred
percent fda-approved food grade
materials it's recyclable and it is
vegan so even vegan producer Pat will
use this filter aqua gear also offers a
recycling program where they will pay
the postage to send back old filters to
be properly recycled and they stand
behind it a hundred percent lifetime
guarantee breakage defects it is all
covered for life and uh just watching
our show or googling tap water
contamination will send you plenty of
stories from all over the country to
confirm that you really do need good
filtration technology and one of the
really cool things about the aqua gear
filter pitcher is that each filter lasts
a hundred and fifty gallons are about
300 Philips before needing replacement
most filters only last a fraction of
that time which makes filter replacement
both a hassle and expensive and the UH
aqua gear filter pitcher leads to great
tasting water which you can learn more
about by using the link in the
description to this video the pitcher is
available on Amazon Prime and you can
use the link in the video description to
check it out read through hundreds of
reviews and if you want to try it by all
means